robert pires est maraîcher à magny les
hameaux il a pu s'installer depuis deux
ans et demi grâce à la mairie qui lui
loue des terres car il fait partie du
réseau amap un réseau de production
locale et d'entre aide
ainsi il peut vendre la totalité de sa
production et en vivre robert aime la
diversité des légumes qu'ils cultivent
des légumes souvent différente en
fonction de la saison
il me reste encore quelques légumes de
divers lacets qui se terminent les
pommes de terre des poireaux des courges
et sur justement lors les légumes de
printemps avoir des fours avait des
choux pointu il a eu besoin d'installer
de nouvelles serres dernièrement les
terres ont en effet besoin de respirer
il faut organiser la rotation des
cultures en fait si vous mettez même
légume de fou de deux années de suite au
même endroit eh ben vous vous épuisez la
terre petit à petit le légume bas ne
poussera pas aussi bien qu'il est temps
de préparer la livraison vers la commune
pour 18 euros vous récupérez chaque
semaine des légumes sans connaître la
quantité ni la variété souvent des
légumes méconnu dont il faut ensuite
imaginé des recettes effectivement passe
son temps sur internet a essayé de
trouver
qu'est-ce qu'on va cuisiner ce soir
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est les
adhérents se retrouvent comme
aujourd'hui pour la distribution mais il
s'agit aussi d'un geste militant
consommer local des légumes sont
proposés mais pas seulement tous les
mercredis à livraison des légumes de
robert donc on a installé sur la commune
depuis
l'année dernière un mercredi sur deux et
en plus les livraisons de volailles
oeufs fromages pains farines ce modèle
porté par la volonté d'adhérents et
d'élus existe dans d'autres communes
pour des consommateurs soucieux de
connaître l'origine des aliments qui
souhaitent privilégier une production
locale